نعم هناك هناك بعض المباني الجديده في
مدينه سرمدا اولت الانهيار وانهارت ولكن
الحمد لله لم يكن هناك مدنيين داخل هذه
الابنيه في مدينه سرمدا ايضا في مدينه
جرابلس على الحدود السوريه التركيه رصدنا
عمليه انهيار لمباني جديده جراء هذه الهزه
التي حدثت منذ ما يقارب العشرين او 15
دقيقه كانت قويه جدا شعاره فيها كل من
المناطق كهرمان مرعش غازي عنتاب وصولا الى
مدينه انطاكيا في تركيا بما يوازيها داخل
اراضي السوريه وسمي المنطقه الشرقيه من
سوريا القامشلي لوصولا الى اللاذقيه كافه
هذه المناطق شعرت بالزلزال هناك بعض
المبانية كما تحدثت في كل من سرمدا واضافه
الى منطقه جرابلس مهارات ماذا يزال عمليات
التواصل واصبحت حقيقه اصعب بكثيرا الدخول
الى العمق الاراضي السوريه من اجل الحصول
على معلومات اتحدث عن المناطق التي تبعد
عن الحدود السوريه التركيه اكثر من 30
كيلومتر هذه المناطق هناك نوع من انقطاع
الاتصال معهم بعد الهزه الارضيه الثانيه
نجد صعوبه في تسجيل المناطق الاكثر تضررا
في تلك المنطقه ولكن لا نزال على حصولنا
على تحديثات للمناطق الاكثر تضررا وهي كما
ذكرتها الاتارب ولكن الان نتحدث عن
المنطقه الغربيه من جبل الزاويه التي يصعب
الوصول اليها ويصعب لمعرفه ما اذا كان
المدنيون كانوا قد سمعوا النداءات بالخروج
خارج الابنيه المهتريه والخروج الى
الاراضي الزراعيه من اجل حمايه انفسهم من
الهزات الارتداديه او حتى الهزات الارضيه
المتوقعه حتى الان نحاول التواصل مع مع
المناطق الاكثر تضررا في العمق السوري
ولكن الامر يبدو يبدو كلما تقدمنا في
المرحله وكما تحدث
رئيس الدفاع المدني انهم يسابقون الوقت
والجميع يسابق الوقت من اجل الحفاظ على ما
بقي من المدنيين